so that chapter is hard on me
it's sort of traumatic to read it
because i struggle with it
um
because i'm in pain most of the time
but i know that it's it's not helpful
to be resentful it's better to be
grateful
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is a
clinical psychologist
a lecturer an author and perhaps most
importantly a man who truly changed my
life for the better
dr jordan peterson welcome back to the
reuben report
it's really good to see you dave gosh uh
well we we connected for about a minute
before we started this officially and
you said boy it's been about
it's been about two years we've texted a
little bit it's
it's been a crazy two years it goes
without saying
so before i get into any of the the meat
of this and i want to talk obviously
about the
about the new book and everything else i
think what's on everyone's mind more
than anything is
how are you just just how are you
well i'm at home and i'm working about a
third of the time i would say
i'm working hard on my podcasts and
youtube
discussions and i can manage about two
hours of work a day
and so i'm not in the hospital and
i'm sharp again reasonably sharp again
trying to write again planning a new
book
we'll see how that goes it's nice to be
back it's nice to be doing these
discussions i've talked to lots of
interesting people over the last couple
of months
douglas murray ion herzeali gadsad
ian um oh i'm going to forget his last
name
mcgillcrist he wrote the master in the
in his emissary
so i'm working a bit and i have this new
book coming out as you mentioned and
that's coming out on the 2nd of march
so that's
ins interesting and exciting and
stressful all of those things
yeah i hope it's well received i can't
evaluate it
you know i'm too close to it to evaluate
it yeah well i have
uh no doubt that there will be plenty of
people evaluating it
and uh you've already sort of dove back
into
dealing with the media so all
all that stuff is kind of coming but you
know you know obviously over the last
two years so much has happened and it
feels like we're in a different
world and everything else and you know
so many people they they asked me about
you they asked me about our time
together and the tour and everything
else
and and truly for me when people ask me
about or just when i think back to that
year i mean we did about 120 stops in
almost 20 countries
you did a bunch more that i couldn't
attend even after that
um it feels like a dream to me like that
that year it was so intense and
wonderful and magical and
sometimes stressful sometimes tiring
whatever it was but it was just
in the summation it was just wonderful
do what what do you
think back on mostly about that well it
seems like a dream to me too
you know would be the last two years
have been mostly hospitals
for one reason or another and i suppose
it's partly dreamlike because of the
vast contrast between 2018 and then 2019
and 2020
i mean that tour was an amazing
experience it was so positive
in you know apart from the odd press
blast
um which were islands of negativity and
a sea of
of of what was positive it was it was
really something to
travel from city to city and to talk to
all those people and
yeah it was an amazing experience and
i'd certainly like to do it again if
if i could gather myself together
i know tammy too had a really uh she
thought it was a great adventure
and i thought you know we worked well
together you and i
it was nice to have some levity
associated with all the seriousness
that's a good combination if you can
pull it off it was so nice to see
all those people who were trying to put
their lives together you know
and and such a remarkable range of
people
i don't want to use the word diverse
because it's been completely poisoned of
course but
there are every sort of person in our
audiences and
and they'd all come together for
for positive reasons as far as i could
tell it sure felt that way
it was so nice to meet people too and
they were always so friendly and
welcoming yeah you know you say
i've been i've been so fortunate in the
response that i've received from people
who've
watched my youtube videos or listened to
the podcast or read the book
it's really sustained me kept me going
yeah it was great it was it was a
ridiculous experience it was
unbelievable that's it
it was unbelievable it was a ridiculous
experience do you
people ask me this too and i actually
don't have a good answer for this but
it beyond just the occasional hit piece
and the strange things the new york
times enforced monogamy thing and the
rest of that
was there anything negative i mean there
was some emotional stuff that was
happening and obviously you found out
that that tammy was ill and thank god
she's better now and
and you were having fun says hello by
the way oh please senator sender my love
mine and david's please do
um but beyond beyond some of that
the the hit piece stuff and and some of
the health stuff that you started to
deal with
and that tammy was yelling do you
remember anything that was negative
i i truly don't it was like every day
that we went somewhere
it was more love more people putting
their lives together and the stories
just the incredible stories that we
heard everywhere
yeah well and you know we did the meet
and greets afterwards and
and i also really liked that you know i
only had 10 to 15 seconds with each
person or couple or family whatever it
was but
that was all extremely positive too so
no
i mean i've tried to figure out why i've
become so ill there's a variety of
reasons um some of it's associated with
this familial proclivity
for depression um no doubt
but i don't believe that it was a
consequence of
certainly not of that tour i mean and
i've always liked my whole life
since i was 25 i've gone flat out i i
like that i like to live like that you
know to work
15 or 16 hours a day flat out and
i mean i did learn how to do that i
thought and be able to sustain it and
so no uh my health wasn't a hundred
percent on that tour
um that was probably a pro droma for
everything that happened later but
i really don't think it had anything to
do with the tour the
now all the controversy that swirled
around me that's a different thing
that that has been extremely stressful
and i don't really know how to
calibrate that you know i watch people
on twitter
and if they say something and 20 people
mob them
that's usually enough to really set them
back on their heels and
and generally people apologize and well
make things worse often by doing that
but
it doesn't take many people to go after
you before
it has a real pronounced emotional
effect and
um you know that happened a lot
and it was somewhat i can't really
understand it exactly why why it
happened so much
um and i i'm sure that had some effect
on me because when it happens
now it certainly wallops me
you know we we had to run in with the
london times the sunday times
a while back and it was unbelievably
stressful two weeks because of that
because you never know of course how the
public is going to respond either
and uh so far as i said
i've been so fortunate in people's
response to me but
i thought well maybe i've gone to the
well of public sympathy one time
too many this time you know um
and it was undoubtedly a mistake
perhaps oh christ i don't know to have
talked to the sunday times
but i thought i had to talk about what
happened to me
to someone and we thought well they're
hypothetically
stayed and reliable you know and it's
it's hurtful to me to see these
institutions
become corrupted you know that i
certainly take no pleasure in seeing
that
it's it's appalling in fact to watch
these these
once great institutions deteriorate into
tabloid-style journalism and and deceit
so but no the tour was great dave i
thought jesus
i mean it's complicated because it also
my life got so disrupted
you know because i was a professor and i
had my clinical practice and
my writing and a business that i ran
as well and now i i'm not a professor at
the moment i'm on leave still
and i don't have my clinical practice
and so
i i'm still i'm adrift to some degree
because of that
you know because that was so much of my
life
and then of course the tour filled that
up and then
well there's a prolonged bout of illness
uh
shared you know my wife and then me i'm
just starting to come to terms with
whatever my new life looks like
i think about going back to the
university but i'm not sure i can do it
and that's very dis what would you say
i don't know how to think about the fact
that maybe i can't do it
i'm certainly not happy about it it's
important do you mean because
because of the physical rigors or just
because you're yeah
yeah yeah just i don't think my i don't
think i'm reliable enough
to take on that responsibility admit
i don't know for sure but but i'm i'm
still very ill
yeah it is i mean i don't even know how
to ask this but i mean is there anything
else you want to address with any of
that stuff i actually don't want to
belabor the point but if there's
anything that you want to get off your
chest i know
now we'll see how it goes no i don't i
don't think so i mean
um if it comes up while we talk that's
fine but
um but no it's i'm so bored of it all
right
it's so dull and and and and appalling
that
that uh we'd better talk about virtually
anything else all right well fear not
i got a couple things there is one thing
i guess there is one thing i should
address steve really
well you know i've been an
advocate for people to put their lives
together and of course my life has
fallen apart and so you might ask
yourself well
are you aware of the irony of that and
the answer to that is
well absolutely you know it's shameful
um i feel that frequently
and then so you might say and people
tweet this out fairly regularly you know
who am i to give advice and i suppose
that's a perfectly
relevant question i guess i've always
thought and i
said this too in the lectures during the
tour that
i don't really think that what i'm doing
is giving advice or if i am i'm also
giving it to me
you know it's not like i believe that i
have all the answers
i have answers that i've found useful
while attempting to move ahead and with
this new book i can show you
this that's what it looks like the black
counterpart to the white book the
previous book
today you know i i wrote a lot of it
while i was extremely ill
and there were some advantages to that i
think in that
i only kept that material
that i felt was reliable under
duress now i think
probably perhaps my creativity was
somewhat compromised
and so that may have impacted the book
negatively but
it made for more severe editing for
example the last chapter is uh
be grateful in spite of your suffering
and
certainly maintaining that gratitude is
something i've struggled with
i think anybody who's in pain
chronically
struggles with resentment but i know
that resentment
poisons and i think that gorm of courage
and so
i stand by what i've written um
you know it's funny i would i would hear
some version of that oh you know people
would ask me when they would ask about
you
and they would say oh well he was
telling people to get their lives
together and here look what happened to
him
and and my answer was always the same
with people which is well first off
he never professed to be jesus he never
professed to be perfect you actually
and this is one of the things that i
think really helped me throughout the
tour
you would often address if you were
struggling with something
you know you from what i saw virtually
every night gave a different lecture
every night and if you were frustrated
by something on a given day
you would address it that night if
something happened with the media
or something was happening personally
and i think people
they see us in these boxes or people
that write books or whatever it is
and they think that we're supposed to be
perfect all the time probably in your
case
certainly more than mine and and it's
just not something that i ever saw you
say about yourself
well luckily luckily and i'm i'm really
stunned by this
you know i thought the other day i'm
going to make an announcement about the
book on tuesday
i think that's march 2nd and i thought
well what do i want to say about it and
what i really wanted to say when i
thought about i thought really what i
want to do is
thank people because you know
this criticism has come up and i think
it's a valid criticism it's like who the
hell is he to talk about
getting his getting people's act
together i mean everyone gets ill
and you know everyone has has
periods of their life where things are
going worse than they might
normally go but people have been on on
the whole
unbelievably patient with me and so
um i'm not sure why that is i mean i
it of course i'm not sure why any of
this is i'm another another thing i
struggle with
is just trying to understand what the
hell's going on
generally speaking and why i've become
such a target for attention
you know both negative and positive
mostly mostly positive thank god
i don't know how i could tolerate it
otherwise so
i still really don't understand it you
know i've been thinking recently
i was reading some material this week
that's uh anti-racist
math curricula you know when it
claims for example that getting the
right answer
insisting that there's a right answer in
mathematics is a sign of
white supremacy culture
and that this isn't some fringe
publication like the la county of
education
has put its name behind it's funded by
the bill and melinda gates foundation
and i do think that the gates foundation
does some good work
um i've been thinking about that
again more and like i think that we're
in a war on competence it's something
like that we're
certainly in a war on the idea of
competence that's why people are
criticizing the idea of meritocracy but
i don't think that it's just a criticism
of the idea of meritocracy i think it's
an assault on the idea of
merit and well we can get back to that
but i i don't i don't think i've come up
with a clearer formulation than that and
for some reason i'm tangled up in that
well i suppose because i believe that
merit exists
so do you see a direct through line to
sort of what put you on the map
in in the larger sense meaning bill c-16
in canada and you started talking about
that and you didn't want the government
to you know enforce or restrict your
ability to speak freely
this was people pen you know pegged you
as somehow anti-trans or something like
that but you didn't want them to be able
to just tell you
what pronouns you could or could not use
do you see a through line
from that moment and that's sort of when
i first heard about you this is now
you know four or five years ago to where
we're at
in terms of the assault on well stem and
there's some kind of through line
i don't i it it eludes me that the
totality
the totality of the of the of the motive
for the culture wars eludes me but i do
think
assault on the idea of competence it's
it's
it's a replay of the canaan abel story
you know bitter attacks on
it's it's it's motivated by some
resentment some deep resentment
and it's easy to be resentment resentful
about competence
the thing is though there's lots of
different forms of competence and
you can have you can allow a society to
exist where there's hierarchies of
competence as long as there's many of
them and
then people can thrive according to
their own
ability and that's good as far as i can
tell
everyone should be able to capitalize on
their strengths
and strengths are always relative and so
and relative strength is merit the
assault on merit leaves everyone bereft
you know if if if people have relative
strengths which they do
and if there is such a thing as strength
which should be something like
relative ability to make a contribution
in a given domain
that's what you trade on that's what you
capitalize on that's what you have to
offer the world
and an assault on merit is an assault on
everyone's strength because
where you're relatively strong is where
you're relatively meritorious
and there's a there's a there's a hard
drive to tear that down
and
and it's it's it's it's driven by
resentment
um and i'm tangled up in it somehow
oh well so many people are tangled up on
in it it's i mean the whole political
situation seems radically
unstable far more so than two years ago
i would say
you know an awful lot of people would
say to me over the last two years
as as the politics got crazier and
crazier man if jordan was around
he'd he'd be fixing some of this stuff
that's an
unbelievable burden and yet i believe it
to be true
that that i think when when your voice
wasn't there
there was suddenly this this hole that
none of us
could fill and and a lot of people who i
think were sort of veering towards order
i think oddly veered towards chaos
well it's very frustrating not to be
able to participate fully
and it's uh you know i have a very
difficult time
coming to terms with it i'm doing what i
can
and i don't think this is over by any
stretch of the imagination i really
think that the
tide that swept through the humanities
and the social sciences is going to
sweep through the stem fields
and with far worse repercussions
well you can feel it coming i mean you
just mentioned math two plus two no
longer equals four
i mean if we've lost that what do we got
it's it's uh and the document itself is
a very
strange document i'm um
it's it's i don't understand it
i don't understand it so
so i want to i want to ask you just one
or two more things that sort of
relative to our past and everything we
did and then and then i want to focus on
the future and i want to focus on on the
new book
but but two of the things that you
really moved me on and i i wrote about
it in my book
uh both of them well one of them was the
core
the idea of having something to believe
in beyond just logic and reason
and and this became you know you had
several debates with sam harris while in
the midst of our tour
i mean you you left to go do these these
incredible debates
but you you completely moved me on this
one i i definitely came from the sam
harris or the stephen pinker or the
jonathan hate
school of logic and reason are enough to
organize societies and that's
that's sort of what humans have and
after a hundred plus shows with you
hearing it over and over again
you moved me on that truly moved me on
that and i wonder if you think
what's the consequence of that being for
you
well a i would say that it's given me
order in the sense that i can't control
everything not only can i not control
everything
but i think this may sound a little
strange i think i have more respect for
the past
than i had before where i thought i
could sort of figure everything out and
figure out
you know certainly what was best for me
and everyone about me and all those
things
i still believe that but there's a
context to it i guess that's what it is
more than anything
it gave me a context and a link to
to my ancestors who i don't think i'm
necessarily
so much better than you know i think
part of the problem now is that everyone
seems to think
oh everyone who came before you was
racist or backwards or unevolved
and that that the the stories i mean
look you did all the biblical lectures
which i watched separately and and you
know
why did you always talk about pinocchio
and wish upon a star that
that there is something else that that
sits beneath
our rationale and without that
the rational mind is sort of lost
and and you really you really moved me
on that
yeah and i i certainly haven't stopped
believing that that's true
i mean we we live inside in some sense
we live inside a story we live inside
the hero myth
for better or worse and that doesn't
mean it's true because
maybe the human race isn't correct you
know
in some final sense but for better or
worse that's still our story to
forge a path into the unknown to face
the darkness to
gather what's valuable and to
disseminate it among
among our compatriots that's us when
we're functioning properly and if the
more you do that the more meaningful
your life is and
and that seems not to be a trivial
matter in fact it's the absolute
opposite of trivia
and i don't know what the metaphysical
significance of that is and that's the
final question the religious types i
talked to jonathan pagio and
orthodox icon carver i've talked to him
quite a few times he's
very devout orthodox christian very very
intelligent man
we've discussed the potential
metaphysical significance of the hero
myth
you know how does it tie into the
ultimate nature of reality and
i don't have an answer for that you know
the christians believe that the hero
myth so to speak
was manifest in its totality in the
figure of christ and
um that's their explanation for how the
narrative world and the
and the empirical world touch and
our whole culture much of our culture is
predicated on that idea
and it's a deep idea and it's not like i
know how to
cope with the paradoxes that it produces
you know i read recently for example
many people will know this that um
according to current catholic doctrine
the theory of evolution is entirely
acceptable
i have no idea how to integrate that
with classic christianity
the time frames are so radically
different um
and i but i also don't think that the
empirical types have
the people that you mentioned this is
the constant discussion i had with sam
they haven't come to terms with the fact
that we see the world
through a structure of value and we
can't get outside of that
so is that why to look at something is
that why
you know during the you said to me from
the day we started the tour and you you
said it to me on almost any given night
um you know you didn't want to know the
questions that i was going to ask you
would always say nothing's off limits
and and i and you would
well actually what you would usually say
to me is have fun or have fun tonight
something like that
but i knew that the only question that i
sensed and i i probably only asked you
once or twice once i realized it
the only question that i sensed you you
didn't want to do because it would take
up too much time
sort of was this because when we would
do the q a and we did it by an app so
people in the audience could
could vote on them there would often be
the okay so
do you believe in god what does that
mean and
and it's sort of what you're talking
about here once you whittle it all down
it we i mean we could do this for the
next six hours if not the rest of our
lives
well you know i've said a lot about that
i
i wouldn't say that my thinking has
really progressed i mean
beyond what i had thought about before i
try to conduct myself as if god exists
i try to conduct myself as if being is
good
that's faith i suppose and i think to
some degree that's also a kind of
courage
i mean i'm not claiming that my faith is
entirely courageous because i
waver of course and and i've especially
wavered
i would say in the last two years given
everything that's happened
all that all the catastrophe that's
rained down upon
my family and i um
but i still believe that
you you become corrupted if you
become resentful about existence you
have
you have to act as if existence is is
good
and that the truth is good and
because otherwise things get worse
and so there's there's a limit
you know there's a there's limits past
which no one can see
and the questions that we're discussing
are at the limit
um yeah well that's it right there the
the
the answer is not clean and i think
every everyone
or so many of us seem to want the clean
answer on that like when you had those
debates with sam like oh
that's the answer that's the winner
that's the knockout blow
and i think you're acknowledging an
uncomfortable truth yeah
the friend of mine the other day he was
raised a communist in poland and
was an atheist and he he went after his
family one year for celebrating
christmas
because it was logically inconsistent
with their beliefs and
which which it was and
but what he told me when we walked was
that he came to realize at one point
that
all that meant was that they would lose
christmas
like yeah it was logically inconsistent
but but
what are you going to replace this with
and it's
clearly the case that people need you
need beliefs to organize your actions
and then i see well what happens when we
when we don't turn to
more traditional forms of belief is we
turn to forms of belief that are far
more
dangerous or at least that lurks as a
possibility as a
as i also don't think it's that easy for
people to defend
like the rationalists for example
they're not doing a great job of
defending the culture
like it doesn't sell well no they're
doing they're doing a horrible job i
would say i
i would say they're doing almost no job
that that woke-ism
is in many ways the the end of the
purely rational
and the and the purely the purely
secular
order ends with what we're seeing now
in some ways i think
let's hope not but but it it it doesn't
seem to be losing its momentum
i don't think i mean it's so hard to get
a uh
an accurate take on the movement of the
culture
you know um it still seems to me that
the education systems are being
corrupted
from top to bottom you know the
university of kansas closed its
humanities department a week ago
well that's partly because people aren't
enrolling in the humanities anymore so
maybe that's you know
maybe the market in some sense will
correct some of this but
um it's proving very difficult
for defenders of enlightenment values
to put up an effective fight against
this assault on the idea of competence
there's no there's nothing solid enough
there for some reason
and well that's that's so here we are
that's it i mean so that that's what
belief sits upon um
all right well you know
let's dive into the book because
actually so many of the things that
we're talking about now
are are sort of part and parcel to all
of the chapters here so
so chapter one and what i really liked
about this also is the way you organized
it
the the the new topics because one of
the questions we would get often in the
in the q a that you would get
is oh was there a was there a 13th rule
that you couldn't get in the book and
and you actually mentioned this
in the book that you had you had what
about 46 other was it 46 42
42 you had 40 yeah the same as douglas
adams answer to the universe life the
universe and everything
42 rules which was actually a
coincidence
but i thought it was comical in the
aftermath but there's 42 rules so now
i've written about 20 i've written
essays about on 24 of them
how did when you got to 42 how long did
you give it before you said okay 42 is
enough
because i know you you're pretty
methodical i just did it in an afternoon
the original list of rules i was playing
on quora
um i i wrote about 40 answers for quora
something like that and i really haven't
partaken in that forum for a long time
now
i was investigating it and some kid had
asked
what what you need to know in order to
lead a good life or what's most
important to know something like that
and i thought well i'll
you know take a crack at answering this
and i made this list of 42 rules and
it got very popular on quora much more
popular
typical pareto distribution like that
one answer got more
views than all of my other answers put
together
and so i thought that was kind of
interesting you know i touched something
for some reason
um and out of that when i was asked by
an agent who contacted me sally harding
um of of of
of cook agency she asked me if i was
interested in writing something more
popular and i knew that those rules
had found an audience so that seemed to
me to be a place to dive in
so anyways i've only written about 24 of
them you know in the two books
they have them both here you can see how
they're how they're
structured ones white and the others
black they make a match set you can read
each of them independently
and one concentrates the first one
an antidote to chaos 12 rules for life
and antidote to chaos does concentrate
on
the consequences of excess uncertainty
and the second book concentrates more on
an excess of
of of order both of those are
fundamental existential dangers as far
as i'm concerned and
in this universe of value in the world
of value there are two major domains and
one domain is the domain of order
and you can technically define it the
domain of order is where you find
yourself
when what you're doing produces the
results you
want and that's that's a really tight
formulation
because it gives you a particular idea
of what a
of what a place and time is the place
and time you occupy is
at any given moment is the place and
time that's defined by your current
goal and you have a map
of value that guides you through the the
actions that are necessary in that
domain and if the result is what you
want
which brings motivation and emotion into
the picture then
while you get what you need or want but
you also validate your theory of
existence
because it's good enough to produce the
results that you desire
and given that you're fallible and that
you don't know everything
you have to use proximal you have to use
proximal truths
and so something is it's it's a
pragmatic it's it's a form of
philosophical pragmatism
you're if you make a bridge and it
stands up then you know how to make a
bridge
why because the bridge stood up now
maybe you over built it you could have
built it more elegantly but
it's sufficiently true so that the
bridge functions and
we're like that we're like engineers
we're cobbling together solutions all
the time and as long as those solutions
work we assume that we're right
well that's that's the domain of order
the domain of chaos emerges when you lay
out a plan
and into action and something other than
what you wanted emerges
and sometimes that can be a catastrophe
an absolute catastrophe and
and your your brain are our
psychophysiological
uh our psychophysiology is actually
adapted to those two domains
um when something unexpected happens
all sorts of emotions and motivations
break loose fight and flight among them
anger among them gets disinhibited
because when you don't know what's
happening you have to prepare for
everything
so you get anxious and then you hyper
prepare which is extremely stressful
and so the domain of chaos is extremely
stressful
in small doses it's exhilarating and
that's because well where you don't when
you're where you don't know what's
happening you have the opportunity to
learn
and to expand your map and so
there's always an interplay between the
domain of chaos and the domain of order
but they can each pathologize and
the pathologies of uncertainty are more
associated with anxiety and nihilism and
depression and
whereas the pathologies of order are
more totalitarian
and then i would say as well the
liberals
liberal types the more left-leaning
types are quite sensitive to
pathologies of order they don't like
them they're
that that's the patriarchy the
patriarchy is
the pathology of order and it's
symbolically masculine something i've
been
you know uh taken to task for claiming
but
the patriarchy itself the idea of the
patriarchy itself is a symbol
the patriarch is a symbol that's why it
has such power
and it's a symbol that refers to the
domain of order
now the domain of order is protective as
well as oppressive but when it
degenerates it becomes oppressive and
i would say it degenerates when it's
based on power rather than competence
but it can be based on competence
you know the the marxist critics and and
and the politically correct types they
insist that every element of the
patriarchy
is only a consequence of the imposition
of order
forceful imposition of order it's all
power well no
no it's not when it degenerates that's
true
because and you can tell that because
the thing is the domain of order will be
upheld by those who inhabit it
if it's functional if you have to use
force that's already an indication that
it's become pathological
because people aren't playing
voluntarily so so would you say
we're in a degenerative
cycle right now that the cycle seems
more degenerative than
than say a building cycle or you think
that that's just the that's just the
play that's always going on and
and you have to figure out your role in
it well i think the play
is always going on there's like and i
don't think like the antidote to chaos
isn't order
and the antidote to order isn't chaos
the antidote to both
is the balancing right the active
balancing of them
you used to do this a lot you would say
the the balance the struggle between
liberal and conservatives so people see
me doing this all the time i always
credit well jordan was talking about
he was talking about this but so you
think that's it well it's really
important it's really important to
understand that
that the that the antidote to chaos in
the final analysis can't just be ordered
because order itself can degenerate
and so i believe that the antidote is
active engagement with the world
honest active engagement with the world
truth and i think it's also truth
motivated by love
which is a motif that runs through this
second book in particular and
love is the desire for all things to
flourish
you know in in in christ says that you
should love your enemies and
that that's an ins that what does that
mean and and it's really worth thinking
about is
you shouldn't wish your enemies harm in
this like
and by by and i what i mean by that is
that it would be better for everyone if
they would conduct themselves so that
they would flourish
you know and that doesn't mean you
shouldn't defend yourself it doesn't
mean that
that soldiers aren't necessary or the
police it doesn't mean any of that it's
not a weak need statement it means that
if you're
if you have your if you have your
if you have yourself pointed in the
right direction
you don't wish an excess of harm on
on the world you want it to flourish
that's love so you aren't yourself
that way and i do believe that that
requires a certain courage because
the world is so flawed and so painful
there's so much suffering in it
it's very difficult to fall in love with
it you keep getting bounced off you
think this is so terrible that maybe it
shouldn't even be
but that takes you down a very bad road
so it's love
first and then truth serves that and i
do think that's the motif that runs
through the old and new testaments
that the combination of those two things
love is the
the desire that being flourish
and and and i do believe that truth
serves that
well that's it no please finish your
thoughts
well i also think that people find
meaning in that
and you can everyone can answer this for
themselves it's like
you have to watch and you have to see
where it is that you find the meaning
that sustains your life and
i would say it's certainly not been my
experience that people find that in
deceit
or hatred i mean they may be tempted by
that they may have the reasons for it
but everyone is ashamed of that
and wishes it could be otherwise even if
they don't know what to do about that
so
well so this book the first chapter is
do not casually denigrate social
institutions or creative achievement and
i picked that
quite carefully because again the
liberal types are more likely to
criticize social institutions um
you don't want to do that casually
because they structure things and
protect you in a way that you're
likely not even aware of and the
conservative
always says look be careful when you
change something because you're changing
a bunch of things and you don't know
what's going to happen
so be careful but social institutions
can become corrupt even just as a
consequence of aging
and so they have to be updated so they
can't stay static
but that doesn't mean you shouldn't
respect them and then creative
achievements on the other side and
conservatives for example they have a
harder time with
open people creative people you know the
best
personality predictor of of liberalism
is high openness which is a creativity
dimension
well it's easy to dismiss
art for example as especially if it
doesn't exactly speak to you but
it's through artistic endeavors through
creative achievement that the process of
update occurs
and so regardless of your political
temperament
you you need to see these these forces
you need to see the value in these
forces and have some respect for them i
think what happens if you get educated
hopefully is that you get educated
beyond the confines of your
temperament so
so so that's why i thought your the
ordering it's so interesting that you
you
said you intentionally of course you
intentionally did it but that so do not
carelessly denigrate social institutions
or creative achievements so that's
chapter one
and i thought it was interesting because
you know one of the things that i've
been talking about
for the last couple years but especially
in the last year and our friend ben
shapiro wrote a whole book about it
is the disintegration of so many of our
institutions
and that i think the the great debate
right now is can some of these
institutions
survive or do we need all new
institutions now
i know you're talking about social
institutions not just academic
institutions or
uh you know we're talking about cultural
institutions
what do you what do you feel in the in
that argument whether can
some things just be left to disintegrate
and
we rebuild or do we do we constantly end
up
in a destruction and a rebirth
because right now we're watching so many
institutions just just crumble
well i tend to start local
when i'm thinking you know so the
because it simplifies things well the
first institution is the sovereign
individual
we don't want to let that crumble
and the more that you're able to live in
a relationship with truth
i would say the better job you're doing
of protecting your
integrity as a sovereign individual
start with that
it would be a shame to lose the family
people derive a tremendous amount of the
meaning of their life from their family
and then those intense relationships i i
don't think we can get
beyond that um
i think you have to knit your family
together
to the best of your ability and i know i
know that people often have terribly
fractured families but we don't have a
good substitute for that
um you need to exist in relationship to
your culture
you need a job or a career something
like that we need political institutions
i i think part of the problem of course
is that everything is
changing so rapidly that it's very
difficult to
it's very difficult to say what should
be kept and what shouldn't be yeah
and and we're not in control of it to
some degree as well
i mean there's in this all-out assault
on the integrity of
of cultural structures but there's also
a technological assault on everything
and so what do you do in a situation
like that well i think
my my sense is you revert to the
individual
how much are they trying to make better
people how much of this do you think has
to do with the speed because actually i
remember
on sort of the last maybe quarter of the
tour one of the things
that you talked about a lot was how the
internet was changing us how the speed
of information was changing us how
how you as a random person no matter
where you are in the world
you might be able to send out a tweet or
create a meme
that could change the world like that
so how much do you think the speed is is
all part of this in ways that were
literally
unimaginable three decades ago i think
it's a
tremendous part of it we don't know what
to do with any of the new technologies
that we've produced and by the time we
adapt to them they'll have transformed
into something completely different
so you know my
my kids are in their late 20s and
they're
more a part of the internet generation
than i am
but they're being supplanted in their
knowledge by younger people already they
can both feel it
it's changing unbelievably quickly
so that that that puts a tremendous
amount of stress on everyone
when you talk about the the creative
achievement
part of this one of the things i've been
thinking about lately is that
i don't remember the last time i heard a
new musician that i really loved or saw
a piece of art that was new
that i really loved you know it seems so
rare we
because of what's happened with cancel
culture that the people that should be
showing us things are not showing them
um what do we do about that
like how do we make the artists brave
again how do we make the people
who will give us the creative
achievement how do we make them see that
star
again well you do you do whatever you
can by example
that's the best that's the best you've
got
you know so hopefully you try to bring
integrity to your
to your endeavors and hopefully that has
a salutary effect
you don't have it you don't have a
better option than that
so so so chapter 2 is
imagine who you could be and then aim
single-mindedly at that and
and for me after being on tour with you
um
i think that's something that that got
into me through osmosis
that i would be on stage and even though
everyone was there for you i thought
hey i'm part of this somehow this this
thing
somehow i became part of this and then
once i realized
that when the pa announcer said my name
that those people knew me i thought
that i'm me i'm the guy they're talking
about like i'm doing something and then
it that just that it helped my aim
it helped my aim and i wonder how many
people just don't
they don't know how to aim because they
have no experience like that
something like that well that's that's
part of what tradition is supposed to
teach you by presenting you with
examples of great people of the past
the lesson is not supposed to be exactly
bow down and worship these people
be like them be like them
and you could be and i mean that's
really the goal of the humanities when
it's the humanities if it's not
if that's the goal then students will
study the humanities
as soon as that ceases to be the goal
then
it it there's there's nothing of value
there
i mean great literature tells you it
tells you the great story of good and
evil
always it's good and evil against the
background of chaos and order
always and the evil characters are there
to
to to be bad examples and the good
characters are there to be good examples
or you see the interplay of those forces
within a single person
and and and it's a reminder of of who
you could be
and you you can find out who you should
be it's actually
this and this is something quite
mysterious i believe and
and part of the proof let's say that we
exist in a world of value
your conscience tells you who you should
be
now that doesn't mean that necessarily
that it's infallible but
people wrestle with their conscience you
know there isn't anyone i've never met
anyone who is
you know i'm not i'm
narcissists accepted let's say
people are generally tormented by their
conscience and
the reason for that is that
they're not they're deviating from
the path that is their destiny i mean if
you don't
think that well then what do you think
what do you think that conscience is
i mean i've asked my classes repeatedly
do you have a little voice in your head
that tells you when you've done
something wrong or you're about to or a
feeling
and they all they all immediately agree
with that no one finds that a foreign
concept and so
if you don't know who you are your
conscience will remind you when you're
sorry if you don't know who you could be
your consonants will remind you when you
deviate and then
you can start to attend to that think
well look
i'm actually ashamed when i do
this i should stop unless i want to be
ashamed all the time it looks like i
should stop
and then maybe you stop doing that and
and then your conscience subjects to
something else and maybe you stop doing
that and
as that happens you start to develop a
vision of who you
could be and the chapter indicates
it it it uh it looks at symbolic
representations
it's an examination of a certain
symbolic representation of the ideal
and so it's my attempt to
assess tradition for what it can tell us
about what the ideal human being might
be like
and the ideal human being is the person
who forthrightly
upholds the traditions of the culture
and forges away into the unknown
we went through that and um and
pulls new information in and builds
rebuilds himself
and the world and that's who you could
be and
now the the the difficulty comes in
figuring out how to do that within the
confines of your own life so in some
sense that's how to bring the divine to
earth
there's this divine pattern but it's
it's general see this is one of the
mysterious things about christianity
that's so remarkable about it is that
there's
there's a there's the the the christ
that's eternal the word of god say so
that's
it's a representation of something
absolutely transcendent
but it's married to the particulars of
one particular time and space and
obviously
um critics of christianity regard that
as one of
its major flaws you know that there's
this idea of god
who is a carpenter in some out of the
way place
in some out of the way time but
you're someone in an out of the way
place at a particular time and place
and for for you what that means is that
for you to make contact with the highest
of values
you have to bring that down to your
particulars
and figure out how you do that it's
going to be a way that no one else does
it because you're
the only one that's you and but you can
you can aim at something aim at
something and the the point of the
chapter is
you aim at something and that will shape
you as you move towards it
and then your aim will change you'll
move but that doesn't matter
it gets you going and you'll be molded
across time
more and more into the person you could
be
can you talk about that just from a
personal perspective as someone that
i've seen do it i mean i i
that's what i saw you do every night you
would take
your your intellectual um curiosity to
to the end of where it would go
sometimes you would get off stage
and say to me oh you know i i took that
as far as i could tonight
and then the next night you would go a
little bit further with it or a little
bit further and i knew
there were moments because we did so
many shows i knew when you were
a little past where you would want to go
and then i could see you
come back but can you talk about what
that was like for you
in terms of your life how you felt how
time felt how
the relationship with the audience felt
when you're when you're doing it right
because i feel like people don't know
that when you're doing it right what
does it feel like
well to begin with and this happened
when i was in graduate school i
had a lot of bad habits i smoked like a
pack of cigarettes a day and
i drank a lot i came from this little
town in northern alberta and
like many little towns especially in
northern canada
that alcohol overuse is de-rigger you
know it's it's
and so um i noticed when i was
in my early 20s that the only time
i really regretted what i had done
was when i was drinking
now it was also interfering with me
writing
because i couldn't concentrate well
enough if i was hungover but i also
couldn't really constant
i couldn't i couldn't tolerate the
emotional strain of what i was writing
about when i was hungover it was too
i couldn't handle being on the edge
because i destabilized my nervous system
in any case i stopped drinking and the
reason for that was well
i decided i didn't want to be ashamed of
what i was doing anymore it seemed
i thought well maybe i could not do
things that were shameful and
then see what my life was like so that
that was sort of on the negative end the
constraint end
um
i think people get on the more positive
end people get
deeply involved in what they're doing if
they're in the right place in the right
time so that
you i would say you can tell this is the
idea of heaven on earth to some degree
when time stops when you're not aware of
the duration of time
when you're so engaged with what you're
doing that you're not aware of the
duration of time
then then you've got the forces of chaos
balance and order balanced
properly it's you're not stultified and
bored
that's an excess of order everything's
too predictable
you're not overwhelmed you're you're
dealing with
it's like it's like it's you're playing
tennis at the peak of your game that's
partly what people experience when
they're great athletes when they play
the zone yeah you know when they're
always stretching themselves to their
limit
you can tell that if you watch a gymnast
for example who has a brilliant
performance they've stretched themselves
beyond their domain of competence during
the performance
and that's what makes everybody leap to
their feet that's
that's the incarnation given embodiment
right there in front of you for some
moments and everyone cheers that on
do you think it's weird how it becomes a
fleeting moment in a way like i
know i know i know what you're saying is
true when i'm when i'm doing what i'm
supposed to be doing
and i'm on my game and and my thoughts
are
are right and straight time just moves
and then i go whoa a month passed a
month passed and i was good that whole
time and i
i did write that whole time and i was
happier and my relationship with david
or whoever else is is better in that
time
but that that it becomes fleeting in
that suddenly you could have a great
month and then suddenly something
happens
chaos returns like it's it's that we
almost forget that moment you can't
like you can't hold it well it requires
a lot of
it requires even to some degree some
good fortune to maintain i certainly
haven't been able to do that while i was
ill
you know and time one of the
consequences of
of my illness whatever it was or
is was time dilation like days lasted
weeks it seemed like minutes lasted
hours and i mean that
literally um that was terrible
the weight of time it's the weight of
brute mortality
it's the weight of self-consciousness
and
you escape that immersed properly
so and that that second chapter is a
pretty practical chapter it's like well
if you're not
who you want to be then think about how
you could be better
take a chance aim at that work at it and
see what happens
so so that's and that's a disciplinary
routine
i would say yeah and it takes you out of
your current order i i think that's also
it's a perfect segue to chapter three
which is do not hide unwanted
things in the fog which seems to me we
live in a constant state of distraction
now you've mentioned twitter a couple of
times it's like
is twitter bringing any of us happiness
or is it keeping us all in a constant
state of fog any
you know the overload and the endless uh
obsession with politics that all seems
like
a fog to me you know i do my august off
the grid and and i do that
yeah i do that to get out of the fog
uh so what was okay distraction is
definitely fog
um and you you'll distract yourself i
think you distract yourself mostly when
your conscience is bothering you
because you don't want to face what it
is in your life
that that is uncomfortable um that
chapter is again quite practical
it it it's a reminder to pay attention
often to negative emotion resentment and
that sort of thing because it can tell
you
well resentment is very useful maybe you
get
maybe your partner is talking to someone
and they're a little bit
more animated than you'd like and you
get jealous and
that jealousy is associated with a whole
set of insecurities
or maybe they're flirting and they
shouldn't be
it's not that easy to determine and
maybe you'll have a big fight about that
but
you could just as well pretend that
didn't happen
you know the emotion comes up i'm
jealous i'm resentful
it's associated with experiences like
that in the past the psychoanalysts
would have called that a complex
you could notice that you could think
well should i be jealous
is there something wrong with me or
there is there's something wrong with my
partner there's something wrong with the
relationship
and you have to untangle that
and who knows what you'll have to
untangle to get that straight
or you can bear the jealousy and see
what'll happen in the relationship or
maybe it'll disintegrate because your
partner is flirting and
you ignore that it's not like you
repress it exactly
and this chapter is an attempt to
distinguish repression from
this hiding in the fog it's that you get
a hint that something's
wrong and then to and then
you have to unpack that hint to pull the
information out
you know so maybe your partner is
flirting and they shouldn't be
and so then you have to find out why
they're dissatisfied with the
relationship or what's
tempting them or or what is crooked in
their
soul at the moment or may or what
they're dissatisfied about
terrible journey of exploration and
discovery
you know that's always presented as
something that's positive it's it's
often not at all it's so hard it's like
doing surgery on
on a separating wound it's and it's no
wonder people avoid it
but it's not helpful you know because
all it does is leave
that that those things grow and multiply
in the dark
and if you ignore them they just cascade
do you think so do you think that's just
self-protection for most people that
most people they
they see it they know that that truth
behind them
whether it's about their partner or
whatever it might be but they just
it's just self-protection like oh i just
got to keep moving on as things are that
we're just creatures of habit
or something like that well sometimes
it's that and it especially gets to be
that if it if it's
if it's accumulated for a long time
because if you wouldn't have d
if you wouldn't deal with it when it was
a kitten you're not going to deal with
it when it's a full-grown lion
yeah and so but i think mostly it's
it's something else i return to in the
book is it's deceit
resentment and arrogance i already know
what i need to know that's arrogance
deceit is i don't have to pay attention
to that
and resentment is well things can go to
hell and so can he or she
you know and that's a that's a pretty
dark triad
and and you don't want the spirit that
embodies that to take over your life
that's for sure well that's so that that
gets us to four then so the or
i think you got the order right on on
these because
uh chapter four is notice that
opportunity lurks
where responsibility has been abdicated
now i think yeah
i think we're seeing an awful lot of
that these days well that's a nice
inversion they because people are often
resentful
if they see that responsibility has been
abdicated why isn't that person doing
their job
it's like well hey man step in at your
workplace
in your family you know when you think
well i don't i shouldn't have to do that
extra work well you shouldn't be
a slave you shouldn't allow yourself to
be tyrannized but
if something bugs you because the
responsibility is
going unfulfilled there's a great
opportunity for you
and this is something i don't think we
teach young people well
and one of the things you may remember
this that was so striking about the tour
was that
i made a case fairly consistently that
most people
find the meaning that sustains them
through the vicissitudes of life
not in happiness but in responsibility
and that would bring everyone to a halt
it would always make the whole theater
silent it's like oh i never thought of
that connection
because maybe you want to avoid
responsibility and you can understand
why
you can understand why you hide from it
like abraham
one of the biblical stories abraham he
stays in his father's tent
till he's like 80 and then god gets fed
up and
tells him to get the hell out and grow
up and everything
that he encounters is catastrophic he
encounters tyranny
the egyptians conspired to steal his
wife he encounters
starvation and war that is what you
encounter if you go out in the world you
think who the hell wants that i don't
want the responsibility it's like well
yes you do
as it turns out that there's nothing
better than responsibility
now you know i say that with some
caution i think that
it's hard to say the responsibility
i've been overwhelmed by my apparent
responsibility
but i think it's also kept me alive and
i mean that literally
and so wait can you can you go a little
deeper with that i mean when you were at
your darkest moments in the last two
years
uh what whatever that might be um was it
the feeling of
there were many times in the last year
where it would be much easier for me
just to be dead
that's constant
so but no
but is it but no because of something in
you or is it but no because of
the the people that you would have
abdicated that responsibility of the
people or is that is that ultimately the
same
thing yeah well i do think that the two
aren't easily distinguishable but it's
definitely that
it's definitely that
you know
and it's it's one of the chapters the
last chapter is be grateful in spite of
your suffering
no
you need a meaning to sustain you
through suffering and it is the case
that you find that in responsibility
well and so it's good advice for anyone
who's at work
you're resentful about this and not
because people aren't pulling their
weight
pull it see what happens you'll become
indispensable
instantly you'll know everything
i know and if and maybe that job won't
be for you or maybe that relationship
won't be for you but you'll take your
hard acquired wisdom go elsewhere and
flourish there
so you know i this kid stopped me i
think i wrote about this in this book
kids stopped me in a restaurant one day
when i was walking in he said
and he was he had an undergraduate
degree and he was
working as a waiter in a chain stake
place
and he stopped me and he said you know
about six months ago i was watching one
of your lectures and i decided to stop
being resentful about my job and he was
resentful because he had a university
degree and he's working as a waiter
you know and look i don't have anything
against waiters it's like
a waiter can make your evening you know
hooray
um he said well i decided i'd start
trying at my job
like really trying as if it was
worthwhile he said he got three
promotions in six months like he's just
rocketing up the power hierarchy well
it's not
power it's competence if it's well run
you know and and and places are full of
opportunity
now
that doesn't mean social structures
aren't sometimes corrupt but
you can discover that too if you start
to take responsibility
and that goes sideways you're not being
credited with that
well then that's an indication that you
you need to
restructure the situation something's
corrupt about it
or if you can't do that you should go
somewhere else where
where that is valued it's a sign that
things aren't right if you're
if you bring your best to the table and
that isn't appreciated
there's something wrong with the table
now that doesn't mean that there's
something wrong with tables always and
everywhere but
it is the case you know that and this is
something we should all get straight
when we think about hierarchies it's
it's an axiom of the left
that hierarchies are predicated on
power it's like no
only when they're corrupt while they're
always corrupt
well yes that means they're all
hierarchies are contaminated with power
well that that isn't the essence of the
hierarchy the essence of the hierarchy
is distinction
of value and that can degen and you need
the distinction of value because you
can't tell what to do otherwise you have
to do the first things
first that's a hierarchy of value that's
not power
unless you're being compelled and then
it's corrupt and you should resist it
do you i'm reminded of uh i don't think
i've thought of this probably in two
years but do you remember we were
in one of the scandinavian countries i
think maybe we were leaving sweden
and we were sitting in the first row of
the plane and do you remember the guy
was a young black man sort of ran onto
the plane he was wearing a yellow vest
he was a he was a worker working the
bridge or something
and he came up to you and he said i'm
not supposed to be on the plane right
now i'm not supposed to say anything
but you helped me turn my life around i
got this job because of you
and what i remember more than anything
is this he had this huge smile on his
face
but it wasn't because you told him to go
out there and be happy
it was because you told him to go out
there and and fix some stuff and and i
think that's exactly what you're talking
about right now
those experiences are so
life sustaining
it's so remarkable to have that happen
and that's something i've had
i've been immensely privileged to
constantly experience although it's
there's also something about it that's
extremely painful
you know the the magnitude of that joy
is sort of
proportional to the obstacles it had to
overcome
while it was attempting to manifest
itself you know and one of the things
i'm sure you saw on the tour
and i don't know how this affected you
was this the
the depth of hunger for encouragement
that exists
everywhere as far as i can tell and
everyone wants
to be appreciated when they bring their
best to the table that's why the assault
the current assault on merit is so
unbelievably brutal because it
will deny everyone the right to be
appreciated
for being their best and
well you might ask well when does the
best become your enemy and
that's easy it's when you flee from it
because the best then tortures and
torments you it's it's your conscience
or the judge
and it's easy to see that as a tyrant
i know that this one was definitely in
sweden
for our first show in sweden i went to h
m to get a hat because it was a windy
day
and i'm standing in line and there's a
young guy standing in front of me and he
tell
i know i told you this way back then but
he he told the cashier he said i'm
buying my first suit this is my first
suit i'm going to see
i'm going to see jordan peterson tonight
and then the cashier said i'm going to
see jordan peterson tonight and then i
tapped the kid on the shoulder
that he saw me oh my god it's you and
then that night at the show i made a
point
of calling him out he told i can't
remember his name but he told me his
name and i said and somewhere here is
ben and he was at hm and he's in his
first suit tonight and the entire
audience stood up and applauded
and he was just a kid he was a kid and i
thought
this is magical this is this is truly
magical uh
yes well it's such it was such fun to
see people dressing up for that
people don't dress up for anything
anymore well and it's too bad
well now we nobody dresses up for
anything no no one goes anywhere but
actually let's just tell them
let's just talk about that for a moment
just that i mean beyond all of the
the misinformation about what they would
say about the audience you know
it's 90 straight white men and it was
usually
60 40 maybe male to female but there
were
there were trans people there there were
black people and gay people and all of
that stuff it's not even worth
going into but that you you always i
thought were sort of fascinated by that
concept that people were dressing up to
go there
that that had some extra meaning to you
i think well it was just
fun to see that you know i had bought
these suits i spent an inordinate amount
of money on the suits that i wore
for that tour but i thought i was going
to bring my a-game to the degree that
that was possible and that meant to pay
attention to every detail that i could
pay attention to and
um it helped i liked the suits i'm happy
about the fact that i did that
made that sacrifice or took that dare
and it was great to see people
put on their best self even just to try
it out
and they did it and it was a little game
that everyone was playing
you know and it was lovely it was so
lovely to see that
yeah and they look good man they look
good
they they did they look damn good you
look great um
well number five then this seems obvious
but i i think a lot of people don't
don't fully get it
do not do not do what you hate
do not well we've talked about that a
little bit already but not so that's a
process of self-realization it's like
well maybe maybe i think it's quite
common if people are promiscuous that
they have post
post-coital regret now i don't imagine
that everyone feels that to the same
degree and maybe there are people who
don't feel it at all
um you should probably watch out for
those people i would say but perhaps not
um if that regret
stays with you perhaps you should
examine what you're doing
and i used that example specifically
because obviously sex is
immensely engaging and so there's
it's tremendously tempting but if the
consequence of that is
the the the emergence of a state of
existence that you hate
well maybe you shouldn't do it and it
doesn't mean well if you're
you know it doesn't mean quit your job
because it's
because it's hard it means
watch and see and if if you hate
something that you do
if it makes you feel small and weak and
sick
sickened and contemptible stop
doing it that's your that's your
morality speaking
to you and the
this is why again why it seems to me
there's many reasons that that morality
it isn't
merely something that we create it has
its existence because
when we violate when we violate our own
moral presuppositions we pay
we make ourselves pay for it why
why don't we just let ourselves off the
hook
if there's nothing real there why bother
with all of that
you know one of the things that i think
about a lot and you know i was going
through this
during the tour but you know i was
dealing with alopecia areata and i had
lost
huge chunks of my hair and there was a
night we were in denmark where i had
this
powder that i would put on to cover the
spots and i accident i left my
toiletry bag in sweden i think and i had
to run to the place and i had to i
basically they didn't have powder i had
to like literally put marker on my head
to hide it i don't even know that i had
told you about it at that point um but
when i was
at that point yeah i i don't think i had
told you and and finally would have been
off the tour
exactly well well actually you told when
i finally did tell you about it and
that's also one of those weird things
why would i have not told you about it
we all
hold these weird things we i don't know
while you were embarrassed and you know
that's not surprising it's that we're
we're very sensitive when things
mar our appearance well then i finally
told you about it and you told me that
you actually had struggled with it
when when you were younger as well but
the reason i mentioned that is
now that i've i've conquered it it's all
it's all mine now
um which is which is great um i do
think that at some level you know i
thought it had only to do with the
amount of hate that i was getting online
and that caused a lot of stress
but i do think at some level it also was
being out of out of state either with my
moral compass
or my uh or my conscience or some of the
other things that you're talking about
being out of sync
yeah there's no doubt that being out of
sync is psychophysiologically stressful
you know if you're torturing yourself
with your conscience if you're at odds
with yourself
you're going to experience that in in
negative emotion like anger for example
and or or or sadness those are those are
intense
physically they're they're they're
highly demanding states they'll do you
in
so it's certainly the case that a bad
conscience can make you ill
in all sorts of ways leave you open to
the invasion of
of pathogens because your immune system
is suppressed or or
or as a consequence in a direct
psychophysiological consequence of
of of of too much too much physiological
activity
yeah did you feel you must have thought
about that for yourself during some of
your
some of your health situations over the
last two years
yes definitely um like i said i don't
i still really don't understand what's
happened to me it's associated with some
immunological problem which did manifest
itself at one
point when i was young in alopecia which
is an autoimmune disorder
other symptoms of autoimmune disorder
but i don't know
and i certainly ask myself to what
degree i'm out of sync with myself
but i haven't been able to sort it out
i have the odd period of time where my
symptoms disappear the pain disappears
then i'm fine as soon as the pain and
the anxiety disappear
i seem to get my feet right away but
anyways bottomless history as far as i
can tell yeah that that
i think a lot of people would find that
really interesting though that the when
the pain
the physical pain disappears that
psychologically you
you feel right now and that because a
lot of people just have
have unearned pain from whatever
whatever physical thing they're going
through but that
that can sort of break the the mental
part of this
or really hamper the mental part of this
yes definitely you know and and
you if you break your back in a car
accident you're going to be in pain
regardless of your
state of moral readiness let's say right
uh chapter six abandon ideology i think
we could all use a little bit of this
right now
well that chapter is is really an
injunction
to allow yourself to think in more
complex terms
it's it's it's useful to reduce a
complex phenomena to its simpler
elements
but it's not useful to reduce it
to the point of absurdity and so
you can explain hierarchical function
using
power you can explain human dynamics
using
sex um if freud did that marx did it
with economics let's say
you can boil down human motivation to a
single dimension and then you can make a
compelling story about why that's
everything but it isn't
everything most things are multivariate
and
a good example of that is the wage gap
between men and women there's lots of
reasons for that many
not one and it's much
more satisfying in some sense if it's
one yeah
partly because then you can identify the
enemy and you cannot be the enemy
and then you can be good and so
oversimplification is satisfying
you often don't have to test out your
theories in the real world to see if
they work
and it can give you an unearned sense of
moral superiority
and so that's what that chapter is about
it's like
well you know it's it's
it's it's an injunction to to allow
yourself to think
complexly what is what's the cause of
poverty for example well systemic
corruption
is one cause but it's one cause
well there's alcoholism there's drug
abuse there's variation in intelligence
there's variation in conscientiousness
there's bad
luck there's there's socioeconomic
context there's
there's there's education there's
endless
contributors and it's because poverty is
not one thing
it's many things and you use it as a
placeholder in conversation but
you shouldn't confuse that placeholder
with a homogeneous category
and ideology does that and
and it's it's it's well it's it's a sign
of unsophisticated thinking
do you sense that that's why sort of the
the woke
ideology or the the marxist ideology
that you were talking about for so long
why it specifically is so dangerous
because there is no
play there is no ability to analyze
something in a different way
where we're generally that's certainly
yeah any ideology
if you really want to solve problems
oversimplified solutions just get in the
way
and so then you end up
focusing on anti-racism in mathematics
teaching
and that's
not helpful in all likelihood or if it's
helpful it's helpful in a small way
chapter seven is work as hard as you
possibly can
at at least one thing and see what
happens
i i know this one worked for me well if
chapter two
was imagine who you could be that this
chapter seven
is um it brings it down to earth
um if you don't know who you should be
pick something
pick something pick something that would
be an accomplishment
even do it somewhat arbitrarily because
you you know maybe you have too many
choices you don't know what you're
interested in
start somewhere aim at something do it
maybe it's a six month certificate at
something maybe it's a
it's an online course whatever pick
something
work hard at it see what happens what
will happen is
well you'll get more disciplined as a
consequence of the work and so that'll
make you a somewhat different
person but also as you work on it
you'll figure out in more detail why
it's for you
or why it's not and then when you make
the next decision you'll be more
informed
that's how a self-correcting cybernetic
system works essentially
you you establish a name and you move
towards it as you move towards it you
gather information
that may shift your aim but you have to
move towards the aim
so so in essence even if you don't
accomplish what you set out to do
that the lessons along the way that
that is the higher lesson at some level
yes well and then
you let's say you should try to
accomplish it
but but i say let's say well you get
halfway through it and you think i
really know this isn't for me
then you might say well how do you know
you're not just copying out yeah
and i would say well you can you can set
up a check against that by
swearing when you start something that
you won't switch it
except for something more difficult
and then because you know everybody has
that tendency to rationalize their
procrastination and that's a good way of
protecting yourself against that
it's like i can quit this but i have to
immediate i have to have a better plan
that's more difficult
and i can jump into that and this is
this is also associated with
something like that the necessary
minimum of respect for tradition
if you pick a goal it'll be a goal
that's a social institution of some sort
virtually with virtual certainty because
it has to be valuable to other people to
be valuable
generally speaking um you want to have
you don't want to be so cynical that you
stop yourself from pursuing
anything because nothing's worthwhile
that's not
helpful and everyone knows that
and you might say well i can't get out
of that cynicism and i would say well
jumping out of the cynicism may be very
difficult try just doing something local
just
pick something you know if you don't
have a relationship
make a dating profile you don't even
have to put it online
but at least you have the profile you're
taking a step in in that direction
you know and i've i've often thought
there's these seven things that people
have to get approximately right
you know we went through some of them
you need an intimate relationship
family job or career you have to take
care of yourself mentally and physically
your health you have to regulate your
drug and alcohol use
you have to use your work time
productively outside of work
there's one other i often mentioned i
can't remember now
it's an arbitrary list in some sense but
if you don't have a list it's a good one
and maybe you can pick one of those
things and work on them and
if you have all of those things your
life is likely to be better
you know maybe you're a true radical and
you have to live in a way that isn't
traditional
and you don't need any of that highly
improbable that that's true
and god only knows how you're going to
find your own way but until you know
that for certain
it's not such a bad idea to adopt an
apprenticeship in at least one of these
areas
and you know the purpose of being an
apprentice isn't so that you're a slave
it's so that you become
capable of your masterpiece you of
transcending the
the discipline so the idea is look
there's lots of disciplinary strategies
there's lots of games you should you
could play
and so you can fall into a moral
relativism say well all games are equal
it's like well no but even if that's
true
the fact that you need a game that isn't
relative that's true you need a game
pick a game which game anyone is better
than none
play it hard see what happens
you'll change as a consequence of the
pursuit
and i think
you have to be in very dire straits
before
that won't work you can be in straits
that are so dire that you can't
move forward but generally
you're somewhere that you could improve
in some manner is is just getting people
to believe that
is that harder than actually doing it in
some ways that that we seem to be
there's so many young people that just
feel so lost that just getting them
just convincing them to do it is is in
some ways more important than doing it
well you i don't think you can convince
them exactly but you can ask
them it's like okay well think about
your life and i do think i'd
address this directly in that chapter
remember sometime you accomplished
something difficult
well was that a good was that good or
not
and generally the human experience as
far as i can tell is that when you've
accomplished something difficult
you regard that as worthwhile so okay so
look that so then you say and this is a
therapeutic technique in some sense
because you don't try to convince people
you you get them to look at their own
experiences like well it turns out that
in your life
when you've done something that
stretched you beyond where you were
so that was difficult that you regarded
that as worthwhile
okay so let's let's assume that that's
uh
that's that's true and that that can be
duplicated
chapter eight i think i've done a good
job at this but i have to mostly give
the credit to david on this one
try to make one room in your home as
beautiful as possible
see something around my favorite chapter
yeah
well you've got some interesting
artistic taste
yeah yeah i suppose um
that's that's a chapter about about the
value of of beauty as a marker for the
transcendent
and it's great you want to establish a
relationship with things that sustain
you
truth the great verities truth beauty
beauty is difficult to define but it's
an invitation to
the transcendent essentially because
beauty speaks of the ideal
and and it it it impacts you
beyond thought it's visceral
beauty and that's an indication of the
power of the ideal
and if you try to establish a
relationship with beauty
and so to do that you can make one
corner of your room beautiful if you can
you start to play with the idea of
beauty you start to learn to
discriminate between what's beautiful
and what isn't
and then you invite that into your life
and that's a scary that's a that's a
terrifying thing to some degree
because beauty is very powerful partly
because it reminds you of who you aren't
but it's amazingly worthwhile and it's
sort of
that the next step beyond cleaning up
your room
you know make it orderly but then the
next step is make it beautiful
and beauty beauty is is a higher value
than order
yeah do you sense that most people
maybe because of the speed that we
talked about before
are not putting the primacy on this you
know we see a lot of people now on
skype and zoom and everything else and
you see a lot of people sitting in
you know some pretty awful looking rooms
and terrible drapes and stuff all over
the place so it is a
a connection to you know clean up your
room in effect well it but there it is
it's that yeah
but well it's not easy and it's and it's
very intimidating you know
um there's a there's a story in there
about color on walls paint and
my my house now is is much different
than it was
a few years ago but it was 32 colors at
one point
and people are very afraid of color
they'll paint their house beige
because they don't want their taste to
be on display
because then it's subject to judgment
and and
often that's wise because generally
speaking
taste is very hard to develop i bought
paintings on ebay for a long time
for a decade and
the ratio of terrible paintings to good
paintings is unimaginably high it's like
a thousand to one right
maybe it's even higher than that almost
everything is
drek um you know and if you're a
beginning artist the probability that
you're gonna produce something
spectacularly ugly is
virtually a hundred percent and
by doing that you demonstrate the the
the
appalling nature of your relationship to
taste and beauty
and that's very intimidating for people
and so
you know they that's partly why it's so
difficult for
artists to make their way because if
you're an established artist
you have a name and then people can buy
your art because of the name
and then that validates the art if
you're a new artist people have to rely
on their own taste
and then their own taste is on display
and that's terrifying and i'm not being
cynical about that i understand
perfectly well why it's terrifying
but to establish a relationship with
beauty is to dare
something it's to dare establishing a
relationship with the divine if you're
atheistic
let's say and but but you're hungering
for meaning
um or maybe even if you're religious and
you're hungering for meaning you can
find it by establishing a relationship
with beauty
and you know i think people understand
this
i think music speaks speaks it most
clearly to people
even people who have terrible drapes
let's say
likely have a genre of music they love
that they find beautiful that speaks to
them in the way that beauty speaks
and music it's so democratic that's one
of the things that's so wonderful about
music is that virtually everyone is
affected profoundly by
music and that's that's a good example
of
the importance of of beauty and the
reality
of of the reality that emerges
when you establish a relationship with
it i mean i do believe that music is one
of the things
that literally keeps people alive you
know i'm reminded of
of many of the uh halls that we were in
the theaters that were in they would
have they would have pianos
down there and sometimes i would get to
the theater you know an hour early
and i'd hear someone playing the piano
and i quickly realized after the first
or second time that it was you and you
were usually
uh you were usually playing off your
head right i mean these were just
sounds that you had in you right yeah
well i'm
i'm kind of a i i really only know three
piano pieces
they're all beethoven sonatas they're
way beyond my ability to play and i've
tried to play them for like 30 years and
i
i can i can't play them now because i
haven't played them for two years
but i got to the point where i could
play them
badly you know but i could actually play
them you're you're being humble peter
come on you were you were pretty good
well
the the improvisation that you heard i
know some
chords not very many and i can improvise
within my
limited domain of chord knowledge and
that's quite fun but
it really is narrow a narrow domain and
um
i've dreamt of expanding it but i've
never i haven't and probably won't
i'm so sensitive to sound now that i
can't play the piano
which is really i couldn't listen to
music for months it was a
terrible loss wow terrible loss it was
it was too
jarring and that association with the
beauty
went it was like the river dried up
the chapters full of poetry not mine um
but
and so it's it's an it's an aesthetic
essay it's supposed to be beautiful
the essay i mean i'm hoping that there's
some beauty in all of the
work and all of the book i always read
my sentences out loud to see if they
have a rhythm um and i always well
that's the poetic element of writing so
people who are out there who want to
write that's something to pay attention
to read your sentences out loud and see
if they have a rhythm
um i'm fortunate i supposed to say do
you know who akira the dawn is
of course no those he's amazing the
synthwave stuff with you and a couple of
the other guys we know it's incredible
incredible i get such a kick out of that
and
it seems that my spontaneous speech has
a rhythm and he's been able to
capitalize on that and
you know i i watch that all the time out
of the corner of my eye because it's
such a strange phenomenon
to be set to music like that but
anyways how important do you think is
the
is the creation part of it so you know
some people can create
incredible sonatas and incredible
paintings um
some people can just appreciate them do
you think it's important that the
creation part is part of what everyone
does or no
i think it depends on who you are i mean
look
openness this personality dimension that
we mentioned creativity essentially
lots of very few people are
profoundly creative just like very few
people are profoundly extroverted or
profoundly agreeable compassionate
there's variation and
i've noticed this in my clinical
practice because i've had
very open people they're probably drawn
to me
but i've also had people in my practice
who weren't open at all
and for them creativity isn't
very important it isn't where they draw
their nourishment
now that doesn't mean they couldn't
establish some relationship with beauty
and i suspect that for some people it's
that's a better pathway than for others
for open people aesthetic beauty is
is bread and butter it's not optional
and and that may even
extend to the creative creating aspect
they have to create
that's their that's who they are you
know just like an extrovert has to go to
social occasions
that's who they are that's their niche
so
but i i think that beauty is
if you can establish a relationship with
it so much the better for you
and i suppose for everyone else too
because then things become more
beautiful
it would be wonderful if we paid more
attention to that because so much of
what we create
is one of the things i'm so stunned that
stuns me
going to europe because
so much of the old european
cities they're so beautiful that they
stop your heart
and you just can't say that about most
modern cities that that's
gone in most modern landscapes it's it's
utilitarian and efficient but
it's by no means beautiful and it's it's
a catastrophic loss
you think of the economic value of the
beauty that's
in in europe and that the tourists that
flock there in the millions the tens of
millions
to immerse themselves in that beauty
even not knowing why they're
doing it it's their communion with the
divine
it really is i mean just to walk around
oxford which i think we did two shows in
and then i went for
uh the speech at the union there it's
extraordinary
it it it's actually mind-blowing you
cannot believe that people put this
together
yes exactly exactly well and then that
tells you something about people doesn't
it
look at what we can do look at what we
can manage
and that's such a gift to to to
to be immersed in that and to
participate in that
and so that's chapter seven so chapter
uh so that's actually chapter eight and
chapter nine
uh chapter nine i thought this one was
really interesting because this i think
maybe came up
more consistently in the q a than than
anything else
uh if old memories still upset you write
write them down carefully and completely
there was a lot of questions related to
this sort of thing where people would
say
okay jordan i've i've followed the 12
rules and i've i'm
i'm not an alcoholic anymore i'm off
drugs i've healed this relationship i
got a better job
some version of all of that but what
they would often say and i think
i i've talked to you about this
sometimes with myself i still felt
guilt about things from the past even
though my life had
moved past them and you would always say
well you should do the self-authoring
uh program which i did do but that in
essence is what you're saying here i
think as well
well if something's still if something
still has emotional resonance
so it's plaguing you it's it's
possessing you
you can't let go of it it's your baggage
you don't want to think about it now
this is
this is look if you're in the midst of a
catastrophe
dwelling on the catastrophe is not
necessarily a good idea
i'm talking about we could use as a rule
of thumb things that happened more than
two years ago
that would be safe because otherwise
maybe they're still going on
and you're immersed in them and you
can't make sense of them
and dwelling on them just makes the
catastrophe worse old memories things
you know you should be over
if they're still emotionally resonant
especially if it's
that the emotion is negative anger fear
hatred resentment something like that
then
there's information locked up in that
that you haven't
unpacked and what that means see because
you build yourself
out of the information that you
encounter in the world
what that means is that part of you is
still stuck
it's as if part of you is still stuck in
that experience
and or it's as if there's territory that
you traversed that you haven't mapped
and so you might fall into the same hole
again
and your emotions are indicating that
they're saying there's a danger there's
danger here there's danger here
there's unprocessed danger here attend
to it or you don't want to
and no wonder you have to dig into it
and then you have to map it and
your map is effective when
you you've rearranged your perceptions
or your behavior so that that event is
unlikely to occur
again in the future that's really the
purpose of your memory is
you remember things so you don't make
the same stupid mistakes again
that's a pragmatic that's the pragmatic
utility of memory
and so you see this to some degree in
psychotherapy
you know this the freudians in
particular emphasized
past trauma and you can emphasize that
far
too much like so that's it's not as if
a therapeutic process should be
necessarily obsessive concerned with
your childhood but if if you're still
plagued by memories
you can't let them go they're not mapped
it's an indication that you have not
fully mined the the
you have not fully benefited from what
you've been offered
there's wisdom laying there and so you
can do that by writing
this happened this is what i remember
this is how it makes me feel well why
did it happen
what could have i done differently
what's the significance now
am i misinterpreting this there's a lot
of clinical stories that i modified
because
for you know concern for my clients
privacy
but i kept the stories intact
you reconfigure your personality by
dealing with what you have not yet dealt
with and then it stops interfering with
your present
so you know what think it might be that
you view your
current the person you have a current
relationship with through the
through eyes that have been affected by
a multitude of relationship
failures and so you're
projecting assumptions onto this person
and
and because you've been hurt
and you have to untangle all of that
before you can get beyond that
and so you catch up with yourself that
way
so that's what that's that's an
injunction to do that
yeah clean up your past and if you don't
it leads to a lot of the other stuff
that that you've been talking about here
uh number 10
uh well it sort of works off the the
relationship part that you just
mentioned
uh plan and work diligently to maintain
the romance
in your relationship you know one of the
things that i consistently saw on the
tour is that you you and tammy really
love each other and there was a lot of
struggles there obviously with her
health at first
but it was just obvious the way you
behave towards you know after every
single show i'd usually go into the
green room with you
we do a little download of you know what
happened and
and then immediately when tammy would
walk in you'd say the same thing every
night
how was it tonight and and you meant it
like you wanted to know
she's the most important person in your
life and you wanted to know what she
thought of what you just did
and that was important
yeah and we're still together despite i
feel bad for her
unfortunately having to live with me at
the current time
it's very difficult and she's certainly
been through her own hell
um but has come out of it
intact so this chapter
romance is like beauty it's a grace it's
a gift
and people and you have to
you have to but you have to work at it
like it's a gift sometimes you fall
romantically in love with someone and
and there'll be the romantic adventures
that go along with that but
it's only a gift for a short time after
that it has to be something that you
strive to attain you know and even
in the initial phases of a relationship
you strive you put your best foot
forward if you're trying to impress the
person you could say well that's being
false but
well maybe it's allowing who you are to
shine through briefly you know if you're
not a complete
psychopath and manipulative you put some
effort into it and then you think well i
fall in love with this person that
should just continue it's like that
isn't how it works you have to
just like if you want your room to be
beautiful you have to buy
paintings and art and you and and and
furniture that's functional and
beautiful and
you have to work at it you have to
attend to it and romance is the same
thing it's
it's vital but it's delicate it's a form
of play
and play in children if any other
motivational state emerges
in a child's psyche they'll stop playing
hunger thirst tire they're tired they're
hot they're cold
they're lonesome all of that will
disrupt play even though play is vital
and romance is the adult form of play
and the conditions have to be set up for
it and so
when i was doing my clinical work i
would say to my clients well
set at least one evening a week aside
for a romantic
adventure and then figure out what
that's going to look like what would you
like well then you have to ask yourself
well what is it that i would like what
do i need and then
that's often real difficult because you
won't even admit it you want to keep it
in the fog
you know you don't want to have the
fight with your partner you don't want
to have the discussion with your partner
you don't want to light candles you feel
foolish you don't want to put on
some clothes that are semi-attractive
because you're embarrassed about your
body or
whatever it might be this is all
extremely difficult
but but you can get
better and better at it and maybe it can
be more than hell do it once a month to
begin with
and and do it badly allow your partner
to be
crabby and not you know fully
immersed in it till you get good at it
you might have to do it 40 times before
you're even
vaguely good at it like anything else
that's complex
but you might as well you might as well
do it
and then then maybe you can keep
the mystery of your partner alive to
some degree and you won't be
so tempted to find your romantic
adventure elsewhere
you know it's funny this may not be the
exact example you're going for here but
i know and
and you got to spend some time with with
david as well but like if i
we've been together for 10 years if i
can make him laugh still which i
try to do every day and i'm usually
pretty good at it it's like to me that's
like the greatest thing like wow after
10 years this guy still thinks i'm funny
like he knows all my tricks
and he still thinks i'm funny that
that's pretty good right there
absolutely well that's a form of play
too
you know and and we
we tammy and i put a lot of effort into
that and it definitely paid off and
we put our we put ourselves on the line
you know she's quite confident
physically
much more so than than i was probably
much more so than i still am and that
was
very helpful to me but
then it's another situation where you
can imagine you could have the perfect
romantic evening
well you could maybe yeah you know like
it's not it's not going to be
easy to get to perfect that's for sure
but you could get to a reasonable
approximation of it
and why not you don't have anything
better to do
than that so that's that chapter
it's very practical the book is like the
first book i thought it's
you know i try to discuss things at the
highest level of
abstraction even a religious level of
abstraction
but it's all very practical it's it's
unbelievably practical actually and i
think that's the secret
um two more so chapter 11 is do not
allow yourself to become resentful
deceitful or arrogant so this is there's
sort of been a through line through a
lot of the other chapters
that have have fit this but but it ain't
easy even when you know you should
that chapter i try to deal forthrightly
with
the domain of human problems and that's
the mythological landscape there's
there's utter chaos when everything
falls apart
and that's symbolized often by the
dragon of chaos an
unbelievably ancient symbol and it's a
symbol of
of everything that conspires against us
it's a symbol of malevolence and evil of
predation
and it's also a symbol of possibility
and it's complicated
and so i won't go into it but dragons
heard treasure
you know and and that's enough enough
said and everyone knows that even though
it
doesn't it that's not
it's a paradox it's not logical it's a
paradox it's the coming together of
opposites
so there's that there's the utter chaos
of of existence
then there's the natural world
conspiring to do you in
at every level constantly and that can
be cancer
which is life gone astray it can be
all the horrors of of of the eating and
the digestion and the and the
reproduction and the whole horrid mess
that that
that's biology and that we're subjected
to
and the beneficiaries of and then
there's culture which is
crushing you constantly to to be a cog
in a functional wheel
and then there's your own black heart
and
all of those things can twist you
against life
and no wonder that makes you resentful
and no wonder
it's no wonder it's a miracle that you
can avoid that but it's
there's nothing about it that's helpful
you become arrogant you can't learn
you become resentful you make everything
worse you become deceitful
you you you corrupt being itself
it's so tempting and so i outline why
it's like look here's what we face
it's it's bleak it's bleak but it's not
only
we all die we have to deal with
self-conscious finitude and the
knowledge
of suffering and the and the knowledge
of injustice
and tyranny all of that and human evil
but
there's nothing good down
those pathways resentment in particular
i think resentment is unbelievably
useful
and so for practical purposes for for
everyone who's listening
if you're resentful about something well
first of all you should notice i'm
resentful and that's kind of humiliating
because
no one's proud of being resentful it's a
shameful emotion
also then why are you resentful well
there's only two reasons as far as i've
been able to tell one is that you're
you're being you're allowing yourself to
be taken advantage of or you're being
taken advantage of
sometimes you're not allowing yourself
sometimes you're a child being abused by
their uncle
you're not allowing yourself you can't
you can't do anything about it
you're resentful because you're being
taken advantage of or because
you're immature
it's one of those two things figure out
which it is and then take
the steps necessary to address it living
a life without resentment is a great
goal
it makes you you watch people drop their
resentment they get younger they get
visibly younger when they drop it it's
amazing to see that
i saw that my clinical clients all the
time they'd be resentful about something
their face would harden they'd get old
and then they'd let it go and sometimes
that was accompanied by tears and
you know you have to let it go lots just
once won't do it
but they'd let it go and then they'd
caught they'd be calm and their face
would be
unlined for for at least for a while
they'd sort of return to
a child-like state of trust or they
would re-attain that that's a better way
of thinking about it
yeah and then you can and then you can
be happy for people around you which was
one of the
one of the rules in the first book and i
i remember when i i'm sure you remember
this when we were in oslo and i walked
into the room
and i said jordan i just got a call i
got a book deal
and you were sitting in a swivel chair
and you slapped your hands together you
spun around in the chair you got up you
had a huge smile on your face
you hugged me tammy got up she had a
huge smile david came in
everybody hugged and it was like you you
were genuinely
it was one i mentioned a couple times in
the book when i saw you live up to the
rules
but it was like you were genuinely happy
there wasn't resentment like oh
now this guy got something it was this
is great well god wouldn't it be lovely
to be able to
enjoy someone else's happiness it's like
it's happiness is precious
and rare and why deny yourself that
if it's from someone else thank god they
get a break from their
catastrophe of their life and wouldn't
it be wonderful if that was happening
all the time you
you closed yourself off so badly being
resentful because everyone else's good
fortune
is equated to your misery how terrible
and that's part of the pathology of this
insistence that our culture is nothing
but a tyranny
if that's the case then anyone who
attains anything within it is only a
tyrant
and that makes everyone's
accomplishments an imposition
and theft from everyone else how awful
well you've been you've been setting it
right for a long time and
i guess that brings us perfectly to
chapter 12 which is be grateful
in spite of your suffering and i think
you probably know a little something
about that's courage
that's courage to be grateful
to remind yourself you know i say grace
with my wife every night
and i need to do that
i actually think in some ways it's the
best part of my day
strangely enough although that's not
saying much
it's very useful to remind myself to be
grateful
and the worse your situation the more
important that is
paradoxically because you can have a
terrible situation and then
also be ungrateful
be resentful and then it's worse
it's much worse
so it's courage what what if i what
what do i have to be grateful for
and to maintain that that's better for
everyone else
so that chapter is hard on me
it's sort of traumatic to read it
because i struggle with it
um
because i'm in pain most of the time
but i know that it's it's not helpful
to be resentful it's better to be
grateful
and you can do that without being naive
it's an act of will
or it's at least something to practice
so that's the book
jordan i uh
i love you man you you helped me turn my
life around because of the things that
you were courageous enough to put out
in the world and uh and i'm honored and
humbled that i was
like this much of the adventure of the
last couple years and i'm
i'm beyond thrilled we had such a good
time we did man we did like it was just
it was
just that's why it feels like a dream
because it was just
there wasn't you know john our tour
manager used to always joke you'd go
this is the most boring tour i've ever
been on no
nobody's uh wrecking hotel rooms and
nobody's
you know beating anybody up and i think
we our running joke was that the worst
thing that happened on the entire tour
was we were in calgary and i
accidentally said that we were in
edmonton which they were not happy about
but no
you were interested in toronto so
they're even worse
all right those two are at least western
canada yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah you committed a cardinal sin
for a canadian
but but truly jordan i it's just so good
to talk to you again and i i can't wait
to see you in person
and i'm i'm thrilled that you're back
nice
when we're out of this coved hell and we
and hopefully everything returns to
everything we had
when everything was normal i walked down
queen street in toronto
kind of a trendy area populated by
galleries and restaurants
and little independent shops you know
what people have poured their heart into
and they're all shuttered
every fourth business is shuttered and
you see the dreams that people
and effort that people poured into these
businesses it's so
it's heart-wrenching to see that all
taken away
i'm amazed that people i'm amazed at how
well people have done with this
i can't believe that things haven't
fallen apart more than they have
i don't know how people are managing but
maybe we'll get lucky and these
vaccines will work and we'll get what we
had back and
maybe we'll be wise enough to appreciate
it a bit more
that would be good wouldn't that be
something if we could only be
appreciative of what we had a year ago
today
before it all kind of fell apart
that would be that would be something
all right
jordan welcome back welcome back and
uh i i i good talking to you
i hope we can continue on this adventure
together and it's good to see you smile
and i'm just
i'm i'm thrilled you're back so thank
you and obviously the link to the book
is down there and all that good stuff
and and please send our love to tammy
and the whole family
if you'd like to see more honest and
insightful conversations with jordan
peterson himself check out our jordan
peterson playlist which includes
every interview i've ever done with him
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist both are right
over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell